[Music]
it appears apocalyptic
the largest fastest most ferocious fire
in california this year
this devastation is not unusual
here states of emergency are an annual
occurrence but every year the fires are
intensifying
[Music]
in mariposa known as the mother of
counties the mother of fires
almost 17 000 acres of land have been
destroyed
an area more than half the size of paris
as well as vehicles
and homes
94 year old ruth clark packed up and
left her home within 10 minutes she's
been living in her car for four days
to see it was getting better with their
planes overhead roaring around like war
zone so i said to my partner let's get
the two cats and get the heck out of
here i had no time to feel sorry to be
fearful all i knew is i had to move fast
daryl coleman struggled to get out quite
as fast because he refused to leave his
21 dogs behind
how have you felt over the last three
days
overwhelmed
alive a lot of stress
um
converting my vehicle into
to carry all my dogs because there's
more dogs on the bottom
not just on the top there on the bottom
too
if you talk to people at this evacuation
center they saw the signs an intense
drought parched vegetation low humidity
and high heat this has long been a
punishing environment where wildfires
were a threat they were possible but now
climate change has helped make them
almost inescapable
as over 6 000 residents are evacuated
out
two and a half thousand firefighters
have been deployed in
they are battling to contain the oak
fire yet three days in just 10 percent
is under control
and this is only the beginning of fire
season which lasts through the summer
and into autumn
for some here there may be many more
dangerous and destructive months ahead
joe pike sky news mariposa california